[Music]
in porn tax news who submitted by is a
secret it's like a sacred Virginia
proposes a porn watching fee an attempt
to reduce human trafficking at what cost
what cost good day sir is that like one
of those slippery slopes where it has no
[ __ ] connection to one another
it sounds like it it sounds like the
weed will get you into crystal meth
right like that kind of [ __ ] it was true
for me honest there's another Weed Man
no he needs to sleep weed I understand
but it was said in the parlance of like
I got to see that two billboards
everyone's talking about the fact that
he understands what the [ __ ] you're
saying is not good dude welcome to my
wavelength now you know what it feels
like to translate what I'm saying is the
craziest day of my life yeah yes me yeah
so there's this new bill being proposed
it's just being proposed as of right now
they haven't like voted on anything or
anything but they're trying to say that
pretty much they would be locking all
pornographic sites from your phones or
computers well what the [ __ ] and the
only way you can unlock them is to pay
this date twenty dollars I feel like
everybody went to strikes like 10
o'clock
everyone just gonna be going to the
borders of Virginia just like white
outside people get to vote on this [ __ ]
because voting is a private affair
it will never pay a lot do twenty bucks
they gotta be more realistic they feel
like thirty cents
they're all still collect a lot of money
they're just being too greedy what if
it's a woman what are your 20 votes oh
that's fine why taxes at all cuz if I
have to pay I have to use my [ __ ] right
[ __ ] that yeah and I
it's not right but I'm just saying look
at any money I'm not using my debit card
or whatever and how they time this to
human trafficking oh yeah so they're
saying that by making pornography less
accessible on the internet that
supposedly oh but there's no correlation
then there's noise it doesn't make any
sense
[ __ ] I I agree with you guys and they're
saying here that others are saying that
this is just a really far-fetched link
so the thing that you stretch it's a do
like human trafficking yes or no oh you
said no well then you should have this
porn tax like it's like that kind of
yeah what it's like well you stole candy
when you're five so obviously you're a
rapist now right you just increase the
price on human trafficking and then
people won't traffic humans as much
maybe I don't think that would make it
in higher demand they should just make
human trafficking illegal oh that it
would give reduce human trafficking they
should put a real high tax on human
trafficking oh you stop murder you stop
killing people you make it a bad idea I
raise your idea and we make it illegal
to murder you chicks have the jiggle
yeah all right
gary oldman in every [ __ ] movie right
it's good picnic so knee and jowl so
who's proposing this is there any other
information on it oh they won't put
their [ __ ] name next to it I know
they're saying like what kind of porn
you're like this is kind of human
traffic you kind of porn so we're gonna
tax this but the bangbus stuff is kind
of cool so it's okay well like the pizza
delivery one is all right or the real
estate one is all you know bangbus is
literally people being traffic yeah yeah
how would you know like this type is
human trafficking porn and this type is
not like you know I'm saying that's a
good question they don't really clarify
that like the Pirates of the Caribbean
parody porn is are they gonna say less
human trafficking I think this is a film
see well I guess
would you guys propose how to stop there
like helps prevent more even by making
any illegal Oh making it more expensive
yeah it's a smart yeah right make it way
more expensive to humans right I did or
hey if we tax gasoline way more it'll be
it'll be more expensive to human traffic
how about this we legalize human
trafficking okay the value of it just
like the other things okay so I'm giving
away Jordans for free instead of selling
it makes it less desire yes interesting
berries oh he's an economist yeah or do
you think it would help if they just
made like prostitution legal but like
the prostitutes no wait no because human
trafficking is basically slavery and
kidnapping and forced sex don't make any
of those things illegal no not those
things what prostitution yes should be
yes should be movable yeah but then a
lot of people are in prostitution they
are being human trafficked people yeah
some of them thought we're here yeah
into you everywhere I thought it was on
Russia
hey everywhere but in fact the Super
Bowl is one of the biggest events for
human traffickers is it all year long
because there's a lot of guys trying to
get boosts as rich as people all in one
place trying to get [ __ ] like so you
have a big facility the Super Bowl is
one of the biggest of the whole year
yeah wow that's crazy I am reading his
book right now called pimp by iceberg
slim he is a real cold-hearted pimp yeah
and he's a peacock remember one yeah
he's quite the picture were the feather
coats and [ __ ] yeah he's an old-school
pan okay but it's pretty sinister a
little bit more than just that you read
I'm only on the first chapter and that's
his before he became a pimp so I'll tell
you more in detail but I heard from Dave
Chappelle and the stories that he had
you just gotta watch this [ __ ] on
Netflix
yeah human trafficking isn't there's no
age it's just any any pay any age but
it's usually [ __ ] that would be illegal
I think majority of it is like sex
slavery
that's the most like part and in like
other than that aside forcing someone to
just work for you so they just don't
people who like people who are sex
trafficking what they just like what
young people like what's the what's the
difference between that and just a
regular prostitute well it's it's
basically making money from something
free oh so it's a money grab thing oh
watch porn do not buy people for sex
that's what I think yes well I just yeah
there's definitely not at work people
who watch porn are actually really cheap
because you could stream that [ __ ] for
free I don't want to pay ya or I'll
still be like I don't have to watch porn
I just don't like the fact that you're
just taking it away tell me have to pay
for it now you're gonna make me watch
more porn yeah guess well I'm gonna
start downloading the [ __ ] now that I
know that what I have is really good and
I don't live over there I'm a much more
important now because I'm appreciative
everyone might move out of Virginia all
the men at least what's it what's in
Virginia you've lived there I lived
there yeah is there anything cool in
Virginia well we used to be really fun
because we simply be able to play
dodgeball but they made that illegal
because it's too competitive yeah
hundred percent no I'm dead serious
they made dodgeball illegal they made
dodgeball illegal so there's two
competitors solve the human trafficking
situation yeah for sure in a Bart
methodology I think Virginia is the
place that people like want to live
cheaply but they all work in DC that's -
yeah the the highest income earners in
Virginia usually working to get DC yeah
but I I think going back to the human
trafficking thing what we need is like a
task force and also like tell the public
like how to look for people that are
being trafficked and then we can like
get rid of all of them I like yours I
think there are tasks they are task
force and that public aren't in the
areas or the human traffic on it where
does it happen I don't know but I feel
like it's in the cracks of society
everywhere every state you have I have
like a some sort of organization that
does that yeah he does that's turn he's
a real clown how often do you guys watch
point
maybe like I used to watch it a lot like
every night used to be like a like a
ritual like you know some people pray
before I go to sleep but then like I
just jackoff before but then but then I
got with Jess and then like now I don't
have to do that that much anymore but
then like now I'm like really it's a
crypto or like you're watching Netflix
videos or whatever and then like
watching my Bitcoin go up and down it
makes me hornier than anything else in
life to it though it's a different kind
of horny it's like it's like dreams and
[ __ ] I'm getting old
[ __ ] I'm getting horny well talking
charts honestly he's turning me on
talking about charts right oh man [ __ ]
it's like wow oh man my future no that's
that's what's happening to me my future
yeah oh I could imagine ma'am I have
some comfortable.i slippers in a really
freaked out I'm with you bet that's all
I think about
I really think about nothing else yeah
even when Dickies making shoes I can get
it and I'm like listen honey I'm looking
at these charts right now they're pretty
[ __ ] juicy over here he just dressed
up as a big old Bitcoin oh yeah
looking at a big [ __ ] green candle
you're like maybe can you just wear this
and then it looks like a Bitcoin a big
Bitcoin I'd [ __ ] the fear out of that
thing I'm all like looking at retirement
stocks and just you know like mm-hmm
having a blast checking out boats I love
looking at boats boats and boats shoes
to go with the boats 100% I always look
at those well what's your answer you're
doing that let me yeah you pervert I
don't know I don't know buddy I stopped
watching porn like a few years ago so
it's like oh yeah you like the woman
corn how do you know I don't want it I
never said I don't watch it I just don't
watch it as honestly straight up
probably like maybe like four or five
times out of a year
you're stuttering too much for me to
believe that should I drink you know why
I want its horn about four or five times
out of the whole [ __ ] you know I kid
you not
it wasn't it wasn't like as fun as it
used to be like I said it's probably
accessibility or some [ __ ] I don't know
what it is a desensitization yeah like
you you just it's that funny more I
don't I don't watch porn cuz I get so
much [ __ ] [ __ ] at home
well yeah you do have two cats so when
the internet first made it accessible
obviously it was like what the [ __ ] this
is amazing but after a while this is the
same [ __ ] it's like having white bread
over and over yeah yeah yeah I was
telling you the same thing I'm I can't
watch porn it's just so boring and it's
routine yeah I don't know it's just let
me finish on her face and what are you
gonna let me finish her about oh we
finished our legs oh let me finish in
our hands they hold your hands out [ __ ]
let me finish on your hands [ __ ] and
you get it to the other stuff it's like
Oh what about the girl that gets
[ __ ] by 50 guys no I don't like this
[ __ ] fell off into the deep end yeah I
think what's gonna have to happen is the
guys gonna just have to open doors and
pull out chairs and we're gonna be like
oh [ __ ] your [ __ ] I do that you don't I
don't know about you jack off from each
other
cookie and even the ones only have to
eat the cookies oh yeah okay on the same
page
yeah well save Agata I heard
[Music]
[Applause]